zu verlieren ich bin eigentlich gekommen
irgendwelche leute jetzt zerstören
gesagt also die wir spielen ja gegen
andreas timm vertan aber gehen mal rein
also mir wird gesagt dass ich irgendwann
wachsen fußball gehört was geschrieben
wird und herrlichen ball und versucht
dann irgendwie nicht zweistellig zu
verlieren
die chance auf fast schon mal gespielt
oder bist du dir echt haben bei facebook
gesehen und facebook videos aber gesagt
habe ich noch nie aber ich stelle das so
richtig und koordinatorin wie zitiert
worden
heute kannst wieder fußball spielt was
denkst du jetzt aus ist lieben oder 0 85
zu 3 für uns lassen
viel spaß beim clash wollen damit die
explosion rein
gut gespielt
du nicht
ja ich finde es hat weder viel spaß
wer gewonnen hat
lösen
und das nächste mal bei action haus